foreign
[Music]
show I'm your host Paul and Westworld
season 4 episode 2 knocks it out the
park as we end up going into a new one
whether you're out of the loop or just
getting into one yourself we're gonna be
breaking down all the Easter eggs hidden
details and our big theories on what's
coming next time wild theories bill now
we open with Clementine pennyfeather who
we see is living a low-key Life by
herself we last saw her in episode 7 of
season 3 when she appeared in Jakarta at
the beginning of the entry she went head
to head with her Dolores copy that was
inside Musashi and this could explain
why Hale ends up sending the man in
Black after her he wants to know where
Maeve is and though this is thought to
take place in the present it could have
happened at any point during the eight
years after the fall of rehoboam they
would of course be searching for her and
Clementine actually ends up getting
reprogrammed so that she becomes part of
their forces Clementine was revealed to
be one of the very first hosts in the
second season and the end of that also
revealed she had a deadly virus within
her and made the hosts attack each other
potentially this could have been studied
by hail in order to figure out a way to
alter human consciousness so we turn on
one another like what we saw with the
cartel we also got our Theory right that
this version of William is the copy that
was introduced at the end of season 3.
as we pointed out in our last breakdown
the real William lost his fingers in the
park whereas this one has all his digits
we'll talk later on about what's
happened to him and we get way more of
the plan laid out now elsewhere we see
Maeve and Caleb who travel out of the
Senator's house that we saw in Brigham's
memory we discover that both he and his
wife are duplicates and that similar to
William they also carry the same
personalities I believe that this is
because helores managed to crack the
Fidelity issues but ended up making
James tell us his immortalization
program break and shut down in the
second season we watched as they
attempted to place his Consciousness
into a machine but this failed over and
over again however season 2 had a post
credit scene in which William returned
to a room in order to test for Fidelity
though humans were unable to crack the
code on how to copy someone and makes
sense that the machines would be able to
as they've existed in host bodies for
their entire lives therefore I think
that hail made this breakthrough and now
she's attempting to replace high-ranking
citizens such as the senator vice
president and as many VIPs as she can we
discover that hail has been hot at work
and also how many that she has in her
Army as of now 249.
[Music]
now the senator and his wife are played
by Jack Coleman and Saffron Burrows who
you might recognize from Heroes and deep
Lucy respectfully Jack Coleman also
played the senator in the office and in
my head Canon it's all connected and
this is the woman that he ended up using
as a cover after he and Angela split up
he also played a senator in Castle and
hey you need a guy to play a politician
he's your host now this leads to a great
fight and interestingly mave suspension
of the host doesn't immediately work on
them she does the old
freeze all motor functions however this
initially fails meaning that she's no
longer the overpowered host that she
once was we discover that Anastasia's
sister was part of the original Park
Massacre that happened all the way at
the end of season 1 and throughout
season 2. therefore he doesn't want to
Grant William the power to open a Parks
which is where we end the episode now
the real Anastasia walks in and she says
the following I'm having the strangest
dream this is similar to the cartel
member last week and as we discussed
buys are actually meant to be Omens in
dreams that show escaping one's reality
in that we watched as the cartel member
woke up and attacked his boss but here
she stabbed in the back by her duplicate
before she potentially attacks her
husband now at this find hail enters
wearing a black dress that's similar to
the one she had in the post-credits
scene of season 3. however here she's
covering up a burned arm whereas there
it was out on display as a reminder I
thought you things could fix yourselves
I wanted to remember who the [ __ ] you
people are later on she ends up bringing
it out making me think that she hit it
here because she was appearing in public
they end up using Anastasia as a guinea
pig and they take her to the barn with
the rest of the livestock they are of
course now forming humanity and from
here we cut to the credits it's a
westwell it's a westwell it's a West
world it's a West world
also I forgot to point out last week
that the skeleton is actually a human
one instead of the house that we've seen
being put in fluid this ends up going in
the same device that William later is in
and we see clouds of gas shooting out of
it that he gets as well the entire setup
with the real William and this opening
is also very similar the drawing of the
Vitruvian Man by Leonardo da Vinci and
he of course ends up as a literal Man in
Black due to the suspension suit that
they Place him in a curtadelas
headquarters which we last saw in season
3. this is the exact same location and
we now see that Clementine is working as
a member of staff there Jim Navarro has
arrived from the justice department and
he's here to investigate terrorism
within the company the slip service paid
to William's very public breakdown and
in season three he was assigned to an
asylum which he then escaped from don't
know how they covered up in murdering
someone in Dubai delos but it's all been
brushed in the rug likely because of
William's connections
we can Crush you
we all know about the mess you made
now in the barn Maven Caleb discover
Anastasia reenacting The Godfather and
there's lots of similarities here to the
cannibal tribe that we met in season one
potentially Hale took across some of the
programming in that and used elements of
it to hypnotize Anastasia into following
a similar narrative but yeah I'd be
lying if I said I knew what was going on
so moving on so she delivers a message
that they're invited to the opening
night of a new park and this sends the
pair off on a mission to investigate
what's going on also Khan showed us the
vid will probably get demonetized but
after Maeve shoots her in the head black
goo oozes out of the wound juxtaposing
the white fluid that came out of the
hosts could further hinder this idea of
reprogramming that hail seems to be
carrying out and they do focus on the
shot for quite a bit making me think
that it isn't just blood now we could to
Christina waking up in bed this of
course not only mirrors her entrance
last time but also several scenes
throughout the season in which
characters wake up in their bed to start
a new day huge alerts to think story for
pointing out last week that the name
Christina also derives from Christ
making her the potential savior of
wherever this place is on the opposite
side of this Dolores means sorrow and we
see how these different names apply to
the character our editor Matt also
pointed out last time that dolores's
painting is called vanishing point which
itself is named after a Westworld
episode now it's Theory time theory time
your time
so the main Theory going around at the
moment that everyone's come up with and
they're all like you need to listen this
Theory and I'm like well let me tell you
this one first and we both say the same
thing is that Christina is stuck in a
park and that we're actually watching
One based on New York everyone's saying
it now this is backed up by the comments
that she overheard last week with the
three men the place is [ __ ] wild do
you believe this is your first time
there's also the fact that the logo for
Olympiad is similar to the delos one and
that she picked up an item with Peter
last week similar to how guests in the
park picked up a can to start a loop
with her although this could all be done
by the creative team to make us go down
the rabbit hole and be like look I've
come up with a theory near listen I do
think it's worth exploring now at the
end of season three Dolores brain was
uploaded into rehoboam and the creative
Team all confirmed that she is quote
unquote dead her brain could still be in
the machine and as we know this was
capable of predicting human behavior
through its algorithm so that Surah
could plot out the future with it as his
guide her having this ability would
explain how she's able to tell the
destiny of characters like Peter as it's
now built into her Consciousness she
could also subconsciously be similar to
a character like Lee Sizemore who wrote
plot lines for the park now she may and
I'm saying may be in the sublime and she
could possibly end up running into
Bernard who traveled there at the end of
season 3. this would allow him to warn
her about the war in humanity and then
he could continue into the future namely
the post-credits scene of season 3. this
story could also be set in the future as
well and as we know Parks tend to be
versions of things from the past so this
would be why they'd stylized it on a
modern New York the tower could simply
be the control Hub in the middle that
everything is ran from and I call this
throwing as much at the wall as possible
to see what sticks now another
interesting Theory comes from Papa
Whiskey on our last video they said that
they think Christina might actually be
the basis for Dolores and that this
could be set far back in the past she
was a writer who pretty much create the
origin story Dolores had in the park
with her father and again that thing
happened now if this is true then a
young Robert Ford could have plucked up
this aspiring young Rudder and along
with her boyfriend Teddy they could have
created the basis for The Two Hosts in
the park there's also the fact that
Dolores wakes up and she still has the
cut on her arm in the park they would
take damage hosts away and heal him
overnight but here we see that it Still
Remains behind so potentially she is
actually human I love this idea and as
much as I love all them and that's the
end of theory time period I'm said about
20 theories there and they're probably
all wrong but see your time so don't get
mad because it's just Theory it's just a
theory now Maya pulls up his obituary
and Christina somewhat recalls writing a
similar story to his life this is later
confirmed when Dolores listens back to
the pitch that she created for him this
talks about him losing his wife job and
also becoming obsessed with a girl that
he stalked which is of course exactly
what happened last episode this makes it
seem like the story was written and then
he was created by who could be building
the hosts if this is indeed a park this
would also mean that if she wrote one
for Teddy he'd be created too which
would allow for him to return now the
obituary list the home he was cared at
due to his mental health issues and she
heads out there however on the way she
bumps into the homeless man once more
and he says this it's killing them the
noise
[Music]
coming from the tower no one could hear
his music but me
the birds moments later she sees several
dead ones on the ground which the rest
of the people in the area don't pick up
on very much comes across like she's Neo
realizing he's in The Matrix and yeah I
love trying to figure out what's going
on with her now he could do a golf
course where William meets the vice
president I love how William wears all
black including his hat which resembles
his outfit in the park again he's got
two fingers here and he constantly hits
a hole in one over and over and over the
guy went from shouting forward to
shouting for a golf joke no no the
senator also drops this line all yours
huh as far as the eye can see
sun's not sitting on you my friend
this is a play on the British Empire who
used to rule so many countries that it
was said the sun would never set on
their domain because of how vast it was
William says that the Park's already
been built and the government obviously
don't want it to go ahead because as we
learned last week robots have been
outlawed also huge alerts to everyone on
that video who pointed out that on the
my brain my choice picture that the AI
pod of brain had been crossed out really
appreciate you guys sending it through
an awesome job anyway it's the most
intimidating round of golf I've ever
seen and it ends with Williams smacking
him over the head William implies that
he'll grow just like he has and at the
park at the end we see him once more
likely a copy Maeve and Caleb end up
attending the party which is revealed to
be the launch of this destination it is
weird that delos would launch a new one
and there has to be another reason for
this as we learn in season 2 the hats at
Westworld ended up scanning someone's
brain and this mapped out their entire
Consciousness Dolores even entered a
library that housed every guest brain
transformed into code but this data was
likely lost due to Hale's death last
week William discussed this at the
Hoover Dam and how they couldn't access
the service so they're potentially
having to remap a lot of the data that
they can't access which is why they're
opening up new parks this episode is
titled well enough alone and this could
be applied to not only Caleb and Maeve
but also Christina they were perfectly
fine not getting wrapped up in this but
they had to dig deeper into what's going
on also I'll probably end up calling
Christina Dolores at some point in the
video just warning you I know who I mean
and you do too just ignore it please
they enter an art deco room which is our
first clue to this park being said in
the 20s Caleb hints that his wife didn't
recognize him when he returned home and
this could further back up the idea that
he didn't indeed die here I don't think
that's the case but it was weird how
they edited the scene to show him
seemingly dying before he was then
revealed to be fine in the next one it'd
have some explaining to do about his
daughter but this is interrupted by the
room moving turns out they're on a train
which was of course the way they I guess
used to enter the park in Westworld you
also get a play on this line by Maeve
and when I finally set foot back on
Solid Ground
what I found was the same
and when I finally set foot back on
Solid Ground first thing I heard was
that goddamn boys good to my dude Jimmy
Navarro from the justice department who
we can hear saying that the VP has had a
big change of heart in his car he's
attacked by Clementine and then Hale
enters and unleashes the Flies the Flies
are a major mystery in the show and they
of course showed up last week with the
cartel boss the intro shows them being
created much like a host and I think at
the moment are likely able to control
and alter someone's brain perhaps they
crawl into the body like what we see
here and they scramble someone's mind so
that they can be manipulated this shot
of a fly crawling across someone's eye
also has callbacks to Dolores who had
one Scuttle across hers in the first
season Plies also appeared in the barn
but they were there because of the horse
bodies rather than being machines at
least I think so [ __ ] shows got me
nitpicking everything haven't seen my
wife for like six weeks man what the
hell is wrong anyway on the train
they're greeted by Sofia who's played by
Lily Simmons this is the same actress
who ended up playing the new Clementine
in Westworld after she was taken out of
the park due to her malfunctioning
Sophia asks if they have any mental
health issues which Caleb wants to
clarify and this is likely because he
suffers from some due to what he's been
through she also asks them to sign a way
where that their personal data can be
used and this has got a hefty list of
terms and conditions that neither of
them read clearly this is a plan to take
their brain patterns and it's going to
use them for what we theorized before
because Theory time never misses even
even when we throw 100 theories out
there that all contradict each other
they're all right every time and that's
because it's Theory time there's also
some lines reused from Williams entrance
starting here everything is bespoke and
exactly your size everything is bespoke
and exactly your size
she also asks if Caleb wants any help
getting dressed similar to the seduction
techniques used on William lastly is the
Hat Choice black and white which was
also married in the shoe Choice my gave
Dolores last week Christina I meant to
say but leave that in and the pair
turned this down because they know
what's really going on Christina right
he arrives at the Hope Center for mental
health which again hammers home the idea
that this is a park potentially feature
world and that's because in Westworld we
had thoughtful on hope so this name Hope
Has likely been repurposed from that
future world was actually the sequel to
the original Westworld movie and there
are rumors that it's one of the many
parks that's popping up this entry
inside Christina finds the Peter Meyer's
Wing showing that the character has been
dead for a long time whereas to her it
just happened recently the hospital has
been shut down for several years and it
also has sketches of the tower season 1
Dolores had issues with time and due to
the house having perfect memories she
constantly jumped back and forth between
her time with young William and also the
present Maya calls her home and she very
much acts as someone who doesn't really
want to get into the bottom of it
similar to the AI creation of Caleb's
bird in season three jump across to the
original William and it's possible that
this takes place just after the
post-credits scene of season three again
lots of timey wimy wibbly wobbly stuff
but it seems like he's just being
introduced to the plan here which would
have probably been told to him eight
years ago when they first started
putting it in motion white light shoots
up the suit mimicking the lights that
ended up on Dolores at the end of season
3 when she was plugged into rehoboam we
then go to the host William's speech
which he delivers at the park this
mirrors forwards in episode 10 in which
he introduced the new narrative with
Teddy and Dolores the train arrives in
Chicago whilst he drops it and we watch
the park start up similar how Westworld
did upon guests entering it everything
then starts up on its loop with the city
coming bustling to life brilliant
episode and I'm fully on board with the
season really enjoy it and a lot of
awesome things going on with it that I
love so far it's got such a great style
of mystery to it that constantly keeps
you guessing over what's going on now I
want to talk more trailer stuff that
might potentially back up some of the
theories in this video even though all
of them alright as we discussed because
too no spoiler alert for this bit
because I know some of you just don't
want to know also if you've enjoyed the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe as we're
going to be doing breakdowns on the show
every week anyway backing up the idea
that Dolores or Christina is inside a
simulation there's a shot in the trailer
that shows a 3D map of New York later on
we see that Christina is indeed there
and it's similar to the maps of the park
that popped him in season one Christina
stands over this I've got Dolores
written down at every single point in
this section in the script but Christina
stands over this at the end of the
teaser showing that she has potentially
discovered it now we also get Caleb
wandering the streets of the city whilst
everyone else is frozen which too is
something that happened in the park this
idea of people from Frozen of course was
there before the host also started up in
the Chicago Recreation so lots of things
going on with that but again what I love
about the series and what's come before
is that you can never out and out say
whether your theory is right you can do
Theory time until you're blue in the
face because you had to run two mile
down the road and shouted the mic to get
that effect but yeah wild stuff going on
anyway that's the video go relax it's
time to unplug but before you do drop a
comment below with your thoughts on
exactly what's going on we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once in the 15th of July and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now say that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
boys which will be linked on screen
right now we've also been covering
stranger things so lots of things on the
channel for you to go check out by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul I'll see you next
time take care peace